اعاده السلطات التونسيه اعتقال رئيس
الحكومه التونسيه الاسبق حماد الجبالي
لتحقيق معه في تهمه تتعلق بعقود ابرمها
اثناء توليه رئاسه الحكومه يتزامن ذلك
ودعوه هيئه الدفاع عن المعتقلين السياسيين
للافراج عنهم بعد استفائهم المده القصوى
للايقاف التحفظي وشهد تونس اعتقالات وسط
دعوات للحوار لانهاء الازمه فيها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما خلفيات اعتقال
شخصيات سياسيه بارزه وقيادات حكوميه سابقه
في الدوله كرئيس الحكومه الاسبق حماد
الجبالي وهل الهدف منها هو التنكيل
بالمعتقلين السياسيين كما تقول هيئه
الدفاع عنهما كيف نقرا السياق العام الذي
جاءت فيها هذه الاعتقالات في ظل ما تشهده
البلاد من ازمات سياسيه واقتصاديه وتعطل
لغه الحوار بين الرئاسه والمعارضه ما افاق
الخروج من الازمه السياسيه التي تشهدها
البلاد منذ الاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي
اعلنها الرئيس قيس سعيد
[موسيقى]
تعود الى اعتقالات بين حين واخر الى
الواجهه في تونس لتذكر بالبعد السياسي
للازمه التي تعصف بها على غير سعيده منذ
ان انقسمت المواقف ازاء مابات يعرف بمسار
الخامس والعشرين من يوليو وما رافقه من
تفاقم للاوضاع الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه في
البلاد على نحو كبير في اخر المستجدات اسم
من الوزن الثقيل هو الرئيس الاسبق للحكومه
حمادي الجبالي بما له من تاريخ عريق مع
حركه النهضه التي تقبع قيادات من صفها
الاول في السجونه التونسيه هيئه الدفاع عن
رئيس الحكومه الاسبق حماد الجبالي قالت
للجزيره ان منوبها يخضع للتحقيق على ذمه
قضيه ماليه بالمجمع القضائي المختص في
الجرائم الماليه وتتعلق القضيه بابرام
عقود اثناء توليه رئاسه الحكومه في
الاثناء يتقاسم لفيف متنوع المشارب من
المعتقلين السياسيين يتقاسمون زنزانات
الاعتقال تحت
التامر على امن الدوله والوقوف وراء تدبير
الازمات الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه التي تمر
بها البلاد هيئه الدفاع عن هؤلاء
المعتقلين ابدت استغرابها لتجديد قادم
حبسهم رغم انهم قضوا في السجون سته اشهر
وهي المده القانونيه القصوى للايقاف
التحفظي هيئه الدفاع اكدت ان ملف قضيه
التامل يخلو من اي حجج او قرى تدين
الموقوفين داعيه لاطلاق سراحهم فورا في
المقابل لم يتوقف الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد
عن اتهام الموقوفين بالتامل على امن
الدوله وعلى اوضاعها الاقتصاديه الصعبه
مشددا على انه لا احد فوق القانون نافيا
ان تكون البلاد قد شهدت اي انتهاك للعداله
او لحقوق الانسان مع ذلك اصدرت منظمات
حقوقيه محليه ودوليه تقارير قالت انها
توثق تدهور الحريات وحقوق الانسان في تونس
بسبب اصرار الرئيس السعيد على الاستفراد
بالحكم وتقويض المكاسب الديمقراطيه التي
جاءت بها الثوره
[موسيقى]
بمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من تونس
فوزي جاب الله المحامي والناشط الحقيقي
وعضو هيئه الدفاع عن المعتقلين السياسيين
ومن مدينه سوسه الشرقيه تونس قيصر الصياح
المحامي والباحث في القانون نبدا معك سيد
فوزي جاب الله سيد فوزي مجموعه من
الاعتقالات تشهدها تونس لقيادات وسياسيين
بارزين
لقيادات من الصف الاول حتى منها رئيس
الحكومه الاسبق السيد الجبالي ما حجم
القانون من السياسه في هذه الاعتقالات
بدايه
اولا شكرا على الدعوه الكريمه وتحيه لك
ولضيفك ولكل مشتاقين
كل مطلع على الحد الادنى من الوضع
القانوني والسياسي وتونس وعلى هذه الملفات
يرى بوضوح انها ملفات سياسيه بشكل مطلق
وانها ملفات مفتعله الهدف الوحيد منها هو
محاصره المعارضه ومحاصره الحياه السياسيه
والقضاء على الاجسام الوسيطه وربما ايضا
ايجاد رائع للسلطه السياسيه لمواصله مخطط
الجمهور سيد فوزي ملف العديد على ذلك
عندما تتحدثون عن ملفات سياسيه تهدف الى
القضاء على المعارضين كيف على ماذا
تستندون في ذلك
نستمد على محتويات الملفات الفارغه موجهه
مثلا مثال القضيه الاشهر ربما في تونس هي
قضيه التعامر المعروفه بقضيه قيام التركي
وعبد الحميد شلاصي وجوه المبارك وبقيه
الموقوفين
تجاوزوا مرحله سته اشهر من التحاق وتم
التمديد ولكن الملف الذي وجهت فيها جميع
التهم من الحجم الثقيل منها التامر على
امن الدوله
بالارهاب يعني كل ما تتصورين من تهامه
ثقيله وتقريبا ليست هناك وقائع باستثناء
حوارات سياسيه بين هؤلاء الاشخاص وهم قاده
سياسيون معروفون في البلاد وكان لدى بعضهم
وليس كلهم مبادره سياسيه لنوعا ما ايجاد
حوار بين المعارضه وتقديمه السياسيه لا
اكثر ولا اقل وليس هناك اي وقايه ماديه
وليس هناك اي محجوز وليس هناك اي شيء يمكن
ان يوفر الحد الادنى من مواجهه التتبع
مثلا نتحدث عن الايقافات التي تم الاستاذ
راشد الغنوشي وهو رئيس اكبر حزب في البلاد
وبغض النظر عن الموقف من النهضه مع او ضد
هذه المساله السياسيه مشروعه لكنه تم
ايقافه من اجل تصريح في ندوه لجبهه
الانقاذ حول تقييم سلام من تجربه الانقاذ
تم ايقاف شخص سياسي معروف من اجل التصريح
وهذا ينطبق على الصحافيين وينطبق على
المحامين وينطبق على كثير من الموقوفين او
الموضوع التتبع في قضايا الموجوده منذ
اكثر من سنه في تونس
السيد قيصر الصياح ساعود اليك فيما يتعلق
بقضيه اتاء امر سيد قيصر الصياح يعني
اتهامات توجه لصحفيين لسياسيين
لمعارضين هل يمكن ان تستند الى حوارات الى
تصريحات من اين هي الادله الدامغه الادله
العينيه
شكرا مساء الخير اهلا اولا هو كدليل قاطع
وحاسم بخصوص الاحالات وما شملته من اشخاص
مختلفين من حيث وتوجهات السياسيه ومن حيث
القيمه والوزن السياسي بدليل لان هناك
صحفيين وهناك رجال اعمال وهناك امليين من
اعلى طراز ونتذكر السيد صابر العجيلي
والسيد عاشور واعلى القيادات الامنيه تم
ايقافها ولا علاقه بالسياسه ولا بالاعمال
ولا بالمال وهذا دليل القاطع ثاني على
توازن التوجه السياسي والقضائي في تونس
والذي يتطابق معايير المتحده وخاصه قرار
39 و43 من القرارات الامم المتحده في خصوص
الايقافات يعني فيما يتعلق
بالاعتقالات فيما يتعلق على سبيل المثال
للحصر قضيه التامر على امن الدوله
المعتقلون تجاوزوا او انقذت المده او مهله
التحفظ عليهم وهي سته اشهر لماذا لم يتم
اطلاق سراحهم اما يحاكم ان كانت هنالك
ادله او يطلق سراحهم كيف يمكن تفسير ذلك
نعم بخصوص قضيه التامر على امن الدوله
الداخلي والخارجي وبعض القضايا الاخرى
التي شاملها ايضا المضاد تجسس بقطع النظر
عن مجموع قضايا اخرى كذلك تتعلق بالحق
العام كلما قضايا تثيره النيابه العموميه
من تلقاء نفسها في اطار كفاله العداله وفي
اطار الحياد التام
ومنطوق قرارات النيابه العموميه اتخذ بعد
دراسه كبيره ومعمقه شملت تقريبا 8000
وثيقه في بعض الملفات يعني حجم كبير عندما
نتحدث عن ملف اي 8000 وثيقه وهذا امر مفزع
في تاريخ الابحاث وفي تاريخ تاريخ التحقيق
والنيابه العموميه عندما قامت هذه الحالات
جزءا منها يتعلق بجرائم بجرائمة من دوله
داخل وجزء منها يتعلق بقضايا حق عام
على معنى الفصل فقط هذه النقطه النيابه
العامه مقيده بالقوانين والنصوص ام انها
تعمل بشكل مطلق
لا النيابه العامه مقيده بنصوص وبالقانون
كان ذلك ماذا عن حق التحفظ وهو سته اشهر
ساجيبك عن هذا فقط وهذا سؤال وجيه وهذا
السؤال وجيه هو مفصل ومحوري كل شخص بريء
الى ان تثبت ادانت بموجب منطوق الفصل 33
من الدستور وكل شخص تم اختراق الاجراءات
في حقه او تم ظلمه على مستوى الاجراءات
الجزائيه فله الحق في الطعن في تلك
القارات الصادره عن قاضي التحقيق والذي
مدد لبعض الاشخاص وليس الكل فتره ايقاف
التحفظ وله في ذلك بواسطه لجان الدفاع
للتكون من خيره الزملاء المحامين بتونس
والذين يقودون الان حمل الدفاع في اطار
نزاهه وفي اطار كفاله حتى هؤلاء الموقوفين
للاسف الشديد البعض منهم محاميين والبعض
منهم سياسيين ولكن اذا كنا نبحث عن دوله
قانون ومؤسسات واستقرار سياسي وقضائي
والايمان بالقضاء فالنبتعد قليلا عن موضوع
التدوين وموضوع رمي الكره الى انها تلك
القضايا هي قضايا ذات سياسي الى اخره وجعل
تلك القضايا ضمن دائره
الحرب هو كسر العظام بين السلطه
فقط في بعض اللحظات
ما قامت به النيابه العموميه هو عمل
اجرائي تقوم بالنيابه العموميه في اطار
كفاله حقوق المتهمين جميعا ولهم في ذلك
الطعم في تلك القرارات
اتحول الى السيد فوزي سيد فوزي اذا حقق
الطعن مكفول وهؤلاء ان كانوا ابرياء لهم
حق الطعن وهنالك اليات واضحه لكيفيه الطعن
وهناك ملفات كثيره امام النيابه العامه
لماذا لا يتم الانتظار الى ان يتم الحكم
في هذه الملفات او اطلاق صراحه هؤلاء قبل
اطلاق الاحكام
لا لا نحن نطلق الاحكام انطلاقا من
تقييمنا لما هو موجود بالملف مع احترامي
لي رم عندما تحدث عن اكثر من 8 وثيقه
سيدتي الكريمه لو فتحت هاتفك وسجلت ما
تتبادلينه مع عائلتك مع اصدقائك مع زملائك
من رسائل وتحولت كل صوره الى وثيقه لوجدت
الاف الوثائق الهاتف كلا منا يعني يوم
ايقاف خيام التركي وايقاف عبد الحميد
الجلاصي لم تكن هناك اي وثيقه في الملف
باستثناء قرارات الاجرائيه او فتح بحث كل
الوثائق تم افتعالها وتم تجميعها من
هواتفهم وهي كلها حوارات سياسيه عندما
نتبادل مع شخص ما حوار سياسي عن طريق
الواتساب او عن طريق الماسنجر بدون شك
ستتعدد الوثائق ليس هناك اي وثيقه ترتبط
بالتهام الضخمه والخطيره والمخيفه التي
وجهت لهم
طبعا تصحيح صغير انه ليست النيابه هي التي
اتخذت قرار حاليا انما هم على ذمه القاضي
التحقيق وقاضي التحقيق الذي استمع لهم
بفيغري 2023 بقي اسابيع عديده وربما اشهر
لم يتقدم اطلاقا في الملف لانه ليس هناك
ما يبحث فيه في
نتعامل مع هذه الملفات سواء الملفات حق
العام او الملفات السياسيه هناك قواعد
للقانون الجزائري وهناك قواعد البحث وهناك
قواعد للتحقيق اي محامي غير تونسي عندما
يطلعها على هذا الملف اذا اتيح الاحتكام
الى اي رجل قانون في العالم
سيصرح بشكل مباشر ان هذه الملفات لا تستحق
حتى
هذه في
ما يتبع القانونيه ولكن تقولون بان ما
يجري هو ذات بعد سياسي ما المقصود بالبعد
السياسي ما الهدف من هذه
الاعتقالات ما الذي تحاول السلطه فعله ان
كان هنالك بعدا سياسيا الى ماذا تؤشرون
تحاول محاصره ومنع جميع الاطراف السياسيه
التي يمكن ان تكون معارضه او التي هي
معارضه من التحرك ومن النشاط وبالتالي
عندما تهدد الطبقه السياسيه عندما تعتقل
المحامين عندما تحتقل الصحفيين عندما
تعتقل رجال صنع الراي العام ستخيف المجتمع
ليس هناك اي استبداد في العالم لا يتجه
الى هذا الاسلوب من خلال محاسبه النخبه
وتخويفها وتمريرها
لنتذكر لانه منذ بعد 25 جويليه تم اعفاء
57 قاضي بقرار احادي بغض النظر على انه
احد وهو تم اعفاء الاغلبيه المطرقه من اجل
رفضهم لايقاف السياسيين
وهو الامر لم يحدث
امر لم يحدث تاريخ تونس ولا في عهد بن علي
ولا في عهد عشر سنوات يعني اعتقد انه
المساله هذه اصلا السيد قيصر رد على ما
ذكرت سيد فوزي ان لم يكن الهدف هو يعني
استبعاد المعارضين تشتيت المعارضه
القضاء على هؤلاء وكما يقول السيد فوزي
استعمل كلمه استبداد لماذا يتم رفض الحوار
من اجل الخروج بالبلاد من ازمتها الحاليه
البلاد تعاني من ازمه اقتصاديه يضاف اليها
ازمه سياسيه ما الذي يمنع الحوار
نعم اولا قبل الجواب عن هذا السؤال سيدتي
النيابه العموميه هي التي تثير التي تمثل
مجتمعات تثير الدعاوي عندما اثرت النيابه
العموميه تلك الدعاوي والى حد اليوم عندما
تم يعني نقله السيد حمادي جبالي لكن تعويل
الفرقه الرابعه وهناك العديد من الزملاء
ويتقدمه السيد مختار الجماعي متواجدون
للبحث في موضوع هذه التهمه النيابه التي
تثير الدعوه العموميه ثم يتعاهدوا بها في
التحقيق وهذا امر اجرائي واضح وليس فيه
نقاش ولا جدال المعارضه شكت في اثاره
النيابه العموميه التي توجد في كافه
العالم
ولا يمكن ان يشكل حضور المحامين ازمه على
كل الاحوال يعني فيما يتعلق بالجانب
السياسي لو سمحت تفضل انت مصر على هذه
الجمله تفضل سيد قيصر نعم نعم ساجيب نعم
ساجيب في الجانب الاجرائي والجانب السياسي
ساجيب في الجانب الاجرائي تم تشكيله
النيابه ثم في قضيه التحقيق ثم في حتى في
القضايا التي بلغ للتعقيم انا اريد ان
اوضح شيء مهم ومهم جدا المعارضه لها كامل
الحق في ان تعارض وهذا امر محسوم في كافه
الديمقراطيات في العالم الان المعارضه عند
تتجه الى كسر العظام وهذا قلناه منذ
ما المقصود بكسر العظام يعني المعارضه من
حقها ان تنتقد المعارضه من حقها ان ترفض
المعارضه من حقها ان تسعى لتشكيل سلطه
جديده ما المقصود بكسر العظام يعني لانه
التهم كبيره كاارهاب كفساد كالتامر وتخابر
والان تتحدث عن كسر عظام
حزب العمال يراسه السيد حمل اماني والسيد
عبير موسى عن الدستوري الان هم احرار
وطلقاء ولم تقوم السلطه بمتابعتهم وللا
يحدثون يجعلون نظام
لو سمحت لي لانه هنالك معلومات تمر يعني
شيماء اي ساعه اعتقلت دون اسباب وتم اطلاق
سراحها ايضا دون توضيح لماذا اعتقلت فيما
يتعلق بعبير موسى هي تنتقد هي تتحدث عن
فساد توجه اتهامات بالجمله واتهامات كبيره
على الرغم من ذلك لا تعتقل وهنا اتوجه
للسيد فوزي جبل الا يمكن ان يشكل ذلك
دليلا على ان السلطه لا تعتقل معارضيها
هنالك عبير موسى ام ان هنالك اسباب اخرى
تمنع هذه عبير موسى ام ان هنالك اسباب
اخرى تمنع هذه الاعتقالات
السلطه تختار من بين معارضيها من تعتقد
بانهم يمثلون خطرا سياسيا فقط عليها توجه
رسائلها من خلالهم تحدثت مع المناضله
والصديقه شيماء عيسى نفس الاوراق المتعلقه
بشيماء عيسى متعلقه ببقيه المتهمين في نفس
الملف تم اطلاق شيما وهذا جيد ولكن لم يتم
اطلاق جميع المتهمين الذين وجهت لهم نفس
التهم والذين تعلقت بهم نفس الملاحظات
ووجهت لهم نفس الاسئله
الاختيار السياسي هذا اختيار السياسي هذا
اختيار سياسي لتخفيف ضغط حقوقي وضغط دولي
والتكارير المنظمات الدوليه والاعلام
الدولي المشكله الرئيسيه في تونس قبل ان
تكون حقوقيه وقبل ان تكون الاجرائيه هي
مشكله سياسيه اذا مشكله
اسمع منك الادوات التي تمتلكها المعارضه
ايضا المعارضه مشتته ايضا المعارضه غير
قادره على توحيد صفوفها بالتالي اي ادوات
تمتلك المعارضه لمواجهه هذه السلطه لدي
اقل من اربع دقائق في هذه الحلقه بعد
بدون شك انه المعارضه التونسيه تعاني من
امراض عديده منها ما ذكرت منها ما هو اكثر
وهي علاقه المعارضه بالجمهور اليوم
المعارضه تقريبا وهذا التقييم الخاص ولا
امثل اي طرف لنا ليست قادره ولا تقدم عرض
سياسي جذاب للجمهور التونسي وهذا احد
ازماته هذا من زاويتها طبعا هي معارضه
ضعيفه ومعارضه هشه فضلا عن انقسامها
ومشاكلها الايديولوجيه بين بعضها ولكن هذا
لا يبرر بقاء البلاد في حاله حكم فردي
بشكل مطلق منذ 25 جويليه منذ اقرار دستور
فردي ماندو احتكار السلطه التشريعيه منذ
هرسله السلطه القضائيه منذ حاليا عن
برلمان لا وزنه ولا قيمه له ولا سلطانه له
يعني في النهايه بغض النظر على كل
التقييمات السياسيه الى اين نسير بهذه
البلاد وهذا
سيد قيصر هذا السؤال يعني ازمه اقتصاديه
ازمه سياسيه عدم استقرار مشاكل بالجمله في
تونس الى اين تذهب البلاد ومسؤوليه من
ايجاد الحلول
هناك ازمه كبيره بين مراكز القوى ومراكز
الضغط السياسي وقلتها عديد المرات
السياسيه او العوالق الحزبيه السياسيه
المتبقيه والتي لا تريد مصلحه للوطن وهذا
ليس عيبا ونحن ندعم المعرض فيما تقوم به
كل
الديمقرا لذلك يتم يا سيد يا سيد قيصر
الذي ذلك يتم قسم ظهر هذه الاحزاب يعني
يمتلك السيد قيس سعيد صلاحيات مطلقه لماذا
لم يستطع الى حد الان ان يحقق استقرارا
لتونس ورخاء اقتصاديا اليس هذا ما وعد به
الاحزاب متواجده على رقحه سياسي وشاركت في
الانتخابات السياسيه وشكلت برلمان وبعد
اسبوعين او ثلاثه هناك مجلس اعلى له
للاقاليم بالدوله التونسيه وهناك استقرار
نوعا ما بخطع النظر سياسي اريد ان اقول
كلمه في خلاصه المعارضه تريد تصدير
المعركه السياسيه الى المنظمات الدوليه
ليس اكثر ولا اقل كما اريد ان اوضح نقطه
مهمه وحاسمه ليس فقط الاستاذ رشيد الغنوشي
او الاشخاص الذين تم ايقافهم هم من
الموقوفين الوحيدين هناك رئيس وزراء سابق
السيد المشيشي اعلان محل تفتيش هناك السيد
يوسف الشاهد الان بالخارج ووجهت عليه عديد
القضايا وهناك كبار كبار رجال الاعمال
بتونس الان محل ملاحقه ليسوا بالسياسيين
ولا علاقه لهم لا بالانتقال كما يقول
السيد فوزي ولاد السياسه وكل ذلك
في دقيقتين في نهايه هذا البرنامج سيد
قيصر سيد فوزي افاق الحل
هو الحل اساسا من يمتلك 99% من الاوراق
حاليا هو رئيس الدوله هو الذي يحتكر
الحياه السياسيه هو الذي يمسك بكل شيء هو
الذي يمكنه ان يوجه البلاد نحو حاله من
الحوار ومن المراجعات الشامله التي تقوم
بها كل الاسرار ويمكنها ان تبني وطنا
مشتركا تتقاسم فيه الاعباء وتنتقل به من
حاله الضعف وحاله انتظار الموجوده الى
حاله متقدمه ولكن حسب ما يبدو كل المؤشرات
الصادره عن رئاسه الجمهوريه وعن الاعوان
الطبيعيه له ليس معه سياسيين رئيس الوزراء
له شهرين تقريبا لم يتكلم لم يقل حتى ما
شاء الله في تونس مثل مقاله نجله بودن
يعني عنا السلطه السياسيه مصره على احتكار
الحياه السياسيه بشكل مطلق وعلى توجيه
التهم معارضها السياسيين وعلى تبرير الوضع
الاقتصادي بشعارات من قبيل الاحتكار هذا
يا سيدي انت الى حد الان سيطرت على الوضع
هنيئا لك افتح للمج الحاله التونسيه
امكانيه التقدم لا يمكن لهذه البلاد ان
تتقدم بهذا الطريق الانفرادي في التفكير
وبدون تقديم اي حل في اي مجال رئيس
الجمهوريه عندما كان يقوم بحملته
الانتخابيه وقبل ان يقوم ب 25 جويليه قال
بان البلاد فيها ثروات كثيره ولكن اللصوص
ونهبوها طيب يا سيدي انت وضعت اللصوص في
السجن وهجرت البقيه وتمتلك كل السلطات وزع
تلك الثروات التي قلت انها موجوده في تونس
على هذا الشعب الكريم دعونا من مساله
انقلاب او غير انقلاب مثلا السياسيه هذه
تجاوزناها هناك امر واقع يجب ان تحلل
المساله السياسيه في البلاد المسؤول الاول
هو رئيس الدوله باعتبار الذي يحتكر السلطه
السياسي المسؤول الثاني هي المعارضه
والنخبه السياسيه التي عليها ان تطور من
نفسها وتقدم خطاب
السيد قيصر الصياح يا سيد قيصر يعني
الحوار لم اسمع منك رد على لماذا لم يتحقق
الى حد الان على الرغم من ان السيد قيصر
يدعو الى الحوار في دول اخرى لحل المشاكل
لا ادعو حتى تونس ادعوا الحوار وقلت عديد
المرات وكنت متواجد في عديد القنوات
التلفزيون قلت هذا قلت ادعو الحوار لكنني
متاسف
لا ينجح الحوار او لا تكتمل اركانه نحن
نتحدث عنك
ساجيبك في ثواني رئيس الدوله وجهه ثلاثه
دعوات الحوار واموال موجوده موفقه اعترفت
بها حتى المعارضه في كل مره تفشل هذه
المحاولات والرئيس الدوله تعال الحوار لكن
هذا الحوار يجب ان يكون ممثلين الامه مع
مجلس النواب وليس مع رئيس الدوله رئيس
الدوله ورئيس جهاز تنفيذي طيب
شكرا لك قيصر قيصر الصياح المحامي في
القانون كنت معنا من مدينه سوسه سيده فوزي
جاب الله المحامي والنشاط الحقوقية الدفاع
عن المعتقلين السياسيين شكرا لك ايضا
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]